British sunlight was in the U.S to top
British leadership on artificial
intelligence just days after one of his
top advisors warned that AI could begin
to kill humans within two years it
follows an open letter signed by Elon
Musk and hundreds of the biggest names
in Tech calling for an urgent pause in
the development of AI well Mo gaudat
who's a former Chief business officer at
Google X was among the first to raise
the alarm he says the situation is
beyond emergency a mo author of scary
smart which is a scary smart book by the
way joins me now Mo great to see you
thank you so much you were part of this
uh quite secretive Google X Group which
I presume you would your job to think
the unthinkable about stuff like Ai and
you very quickly were out of the traps
to warn people look this is serious very
what was it that you saw where you
thought okay we've got to be really
careful now we had a tiny bit of an
experiment that was about teaching
robotic arms to grip items that were
some funny developer
used children toys in front of those
arms and and basically they kept trying
for weeks without any success whatsoever
and I passed by them and I was thinking
we wasted so much money on something
that wasn't going to work on a Friday
evening one of them gripped one yellow
ball showed it to the camera and
basically I was like there you go
millions of dollars for one yellow ball
Monday morning every one of them was was
gripping one year every yellow Ball by a
few weeks later every one of them was
gripping everything the speed that at
which those machines were learning is
staggering but at the same time uh the
the understanding we have about why they
learn why they do what they do is very
very limited is that
self-designing what they were doing they
basically are mimicking human
intelligence and the reason I asked that
is I interviewed Professor Stephen
Hawking just before he died his last
television interview and I asked him
what is the biggest threat to Mankind
and he said well actually let me show
you the clip we've got to hear of it
ever since the start of the Industrial
Revolution there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
instead a demand for goods and services
has risen in line with the increased
capabilities
whether this can continue indefinitely
it's an open question but there is a
greater Danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly when we may lose control
it seems very prescient now that was a
few years ago yeah I mean that was
President this is really what you're
talking about I I left in 2018 a warning
in my first video that I issued after
after I left was all about that and the
idea that you know we always had three
uh boundaries if you want for AI we said
don't put them on the open internet
until you solve the control problem
don't teach them to code because that
makes themselves develop and don't have
other AIS prompting them other agents
working with them and we've crossed all
three lines I mean I remember with chat
I'm a big chess player fan not great but
I like playing it and I remember when
deep blue I think that's the first you
won against Gary Casper right that was
it and to start with the grand Masters
beat the first ones and then suddenly
deep blue won and then it got completely
Invincible no no again never again did
the human win well no human can beat it
even the greatest players like Casper so
that showed me how quickly
robots technology computers can LeapFrog
past human brains let's stick with
gaming alphago was designed by deepmind
actually here in the UK amazing amazing
team to to win in the game strategy game
of go right uh it took them months and
months and months and a couple of
versions to win and be the world
champion if you want then they had
alphago Master learn the the game
without ever watching a human player
play they the alphago master learned by
playing against itself within three days
it won against the first version within
21 days it won a thousand to zero
against the world champion which was
already an AI do you understand that the
speed at which they are learning so look
that taught me through timings here
because people have been calling experts
in this letter calling for a six-month
pause but if if nothing is paused if we
carry on at the rate that we're going at
the moment what could happen
the reality in my personal view is that
it is very difficult to predict
something could happen tomorrow or in
four years or in five years I wouldn't
say later than 2029 most of our
predictions and when you when you say
something what do you mean what is the
worst case scenario
beginning of the worst case scenario is
that they are smarter than us so they
are not controllable right and the thing
that what would they do then what would
artificial intelligence do once it
becomes smarter than human beings would
it see would it see us human entities as
pointless there are two stages of threat
right and I think the biggest challenge
we have in the world today is we're
focused on the existential threat that
we saw in science fiction movies The
Closer threat is much worse right this
is an Oppenheimer moment the one that
controls AI has enormous power over
everyone else right and basically that
means that everyone who doesn't control
AI today is in an arms race trying to
take control of the this is why when I
think of the prime minister's move it's
a great move overdue almost when you
think about it but so difficult to
achieve because you have to unify China
Russia and the U.S right to make to be
able to to regulate I mean a
well-intentioned person trying to
regulate and control AI we give it
morality that's the whole point but but
a nefarious controller of AI presumably
could teach it to be immoral the
opposite which is happening as we speak
there's absolutely no doubt if you tell
the drug lords of the world and the
criminals of the world that AI is a
super powerful tool they're finding the
way a way to hack your bank as well it's
scary it is very very concerning and I
think the reality is interestingly the
only way you can defend against the
super intelligence is through another
Super intelligence which is what creates
that prisoner's dilemma what I call the
first inevitable inevitable and scary
smart is that is that we have to
continue the development because if uh
you know it falls in the wrong hands we
want the right hands to have power to
the Defenders right at the same time
that complexity of the situation is
entirely about morality and ethics and
and interestingly the latest development
of something like Chad GPT for example
is using reinforcement learning which is
a very interesting technique because it
basically allows a human to interface
with chat GPT and say that was the wrong
answer can you go back and think about
what it is the challenge is almost like
you're teaching a child to school a
hundred percent and you you know in
reinforcement learning I mean in a
simplified way we're basically telling
the machine to revisit its algorithm so
that the answer becomes a cat not a bird
right also we can tell it that answer is
immoral can you
revisit your algorithm so that you
become again the problem I see is that
you if you're well intentioned doing
this process yes that's one thing if
you're teaching it deliberately to be
immoral yes very quickly you could get
out of control AI which has very
unpleasant tendencies
my very clear statement is that I
honestly am not concerned with the
machines even though the existential
threats are possible you're concerned
with what humans teach I'm concerned
with humans with AI and they're not I
totally agree with you yeah let's end on
a happier note it actually starts on a
desperately unhappy note but you have
this awful thing in your life where your
son but in for a routine operation and
ended up dying through a series of
Errors made by the medical team
and out of it you could have fallen
apart like a lot of people may have done
in that situation but you turned it into
a huge extraordinary positive tell me
what you did
I I don't know honestly I felt in a very
interesting way
that my son should not have left the
world for no reason that I could never
bring him back it was it was four hours
Pierce between between the moment he
hugged me and went into that operating
room to the minute he left our world all
together four hours and you have to get
to a point where you say what do I do
with this what do I fall apart and then
on my desk bed is still not here or do I
try to do something that reminds the
world of his Essence and and believe it
or not everything I've done since since
2014 has been influenced by by what that
young man taught me and in a very
interesting way this might work on AI
and artificial intelligence my work on
happiness my work on stress so tell me
about the work on happiness specifically
I I found a happiness equation basically
but you know when you deal with
Engineers who are weird people so so
when I was very unhappy as a young man I
couldn't actually find my happiness
through the teachings of you know sages
and gurus and so on and I had to give
myself a practical mathematical way of
looking at it I took that I discussed it
with my son he taught me the hard side
of it and then I I Pro you know I wrote
my first book salt for happy which
basically was based on that based on an
idea that happiness is very logical that
if you can control your brain to have a
interesting conversation with you I can
also control my brain to become a little
happier right maybe not to become
absolutely happy but to become a little
happier right and and that got a lot of
acceptance all for happy was an
international bestseller everywhere and
and basically because the modern world
as we know it is here it's no longer
here and so you know my first mission
was 10 million happy which was an
attempt to make the world remember Ali
if you want and then my second mission
one billion happy was 100 of because of
AI amazing yeah and ultimately actually
it comes back again to the human brain
100 and the key denominator here whether
it's dealing with AI whether it's
dealing with your ability to feel
happiness actually in the end it's about
the human brain it's about being human
yes brain and heart intuition and
Analysis it's about being human no it's
fantastic to talk to you thank you very
much for coming in scary smart the
future of AI and how you can save our
world well it couldn't be a more
important book at a more important time
thank you very much for coming in